and I was finally showing my work at the
fancy New York Film Festival every
filmmaker's
dream mom what do you think you do this
to hurt
me I always like to go back and start at
the beginning with people and sort of
ask what was your first job in this
business the first time you felt you
could call yourself an editor the first
time you cast something even if it was
you know like a friend short film my
first job in the industry was at a
company that made cast made for TV
movies for the Hallmark Channel and
lifetime a lot of Christmas titles and a
lot of girls who work in a bakery and
this sort of thing lots of ghosts too A
lot of those movies have ghosts in
them for you um for me I had worked with
um writer director John Ridley on uh a
feature Indie of his and the editor had
to step away and then I had the
opportunity to kind of jump in and fill
that role while he went off and did some
other things um and there was a moment
where I was used to being an assistant
um and he came over and he asked me
something and I kind of hesitated you
know I was like I don't know and he
looked at me and said you're all I've
got so I pulled it together and actually
gave him my opinion
um and then I ended up he um did a TV
show soon after and made me an editor
wow that's so your first like editing
credit out of the gate is with John
Ridley yes yes wow that's
amazing um well here we are with the
Persian version um and this film comes
to us courtesy of writer director maram
kesavar and it won both the audience
award and the Waldo SW salt
screenwriting award when it premiered at
the Sundance Film Festival earlier this
year um but how did the project first
come to you I had worked with a friend
of hers Jamie babbit and they were
moving um from cutting in London to LA
and they needed somebody in LA and um
she had recommended me so I met with
Miriam I was very um kind of tired and
not ready for to take on another job but
miam's very convincing um she knew what
she was doing she she's like come over
for coffee uh and then she just suddenly
a laptop was in my lap and I was
watching her movie and and uh it was
hard to say no after that um so I I came
on later into the process um and really
I had the opportunity to see it as a
full film at that point and you know
obviously there was more work that
needed to be done but I could see it was
already you know something really
special um Abu uh tone is the editor
that really did a bulk of the work on
this um and a wonderful job and he was
you know very open and um fully
encouraged you you know me it was a nice
collaboration sort of after the fact
yeah and Lindsay for you I was brought
into meet Mariam by a producer that I
had worked with before Natalie Kasabian
on a feature film called
searching and she introduced the two of
us she sent me the script and what I
look for in a script when I want to come
on board to cast is are actors going to
want to play these roles how hard is my
job going to be um to convince actors to
be in this movie and I would not have to
convince a single person to be in this
movie I just thought it was the best
script I've ever read and also miam
seemed like just the most incredible
creative Force to have the opportunity
to work with and so I came on board very
early just to start looking for the two
leads the mother and the daughter Leila
mohamadi and NAA uh who I believe along
in the conversation for Academy Award
for this mie I was blown away by their
performances they did audition for the
movie in
2019 but after coid we had some delays
and didn't end up actually casting
anybody until a couple years later wow
um I was thinking when you were saying
you wouldn't have to convince any actors
to to to be involved in this project how
rare is it to see you know a a woman of
color lead role so dynamic complex and
this film has two of them really kind of
four because they also you also had to
cast the younger versions of them um did
you find you know was was it a hard film
to cast or did you find people were were
hungry for this kind of material oh
absolutely anybody we asked to audition
or consider the
film was happy to be considered or to
audition whatever we were asking you
know I came into casting about maybe 16
years ago at this point and the IND
industry has changed so
much every year that goes by casting a
film like this becomes easier and easier
but I believe that because of films like
this because of women of color leads and
just such amazing characters on screen
that young people will see themselves
reflected in movies like this who never
before thought they could become an
actor who never before thought that
there ever could be a role for them and
I believe we'll just have more and more
options of that represent all kinds of
backgrounds and cultures and shapes and
sizes and orientations in the future and
I really believe that we're headed in
the right direction can we talk about
sort of where you found I don't know if
you were familiar with the work of your
two leads I mean uh Leila
Lea yes she's such a breakout in this
movie I was blown away by her and she is
a hardworking young actress who's been
pursuing a career since she was a young
teen she just Rose to the occasion every
step of the way as did all of the actors
nusa as well we chemistry read them
together and it was just such a fit and
I just think both of them stepped up to
the play and more Joan you've worked on
such a wide variety of genres and and
projects that mix comedy with drama like
only murders in the building which is
the best show on TV how do you sort of
find that balance of tones in the
editing often times
you know you you feel that sort of
tension building in those dramatic
scenes and really an audience is craving
a little bit of a release so sometimes
there's a little joke and it doesn't
even have to be that funny people are
like ah you know they just need that
release um it's it's funny as an editor
we get typ cast as well and so it's nice
to be able to jump around and and show
that you can kind of do everything and
so when a project comes along that you
know has multiple elements it makes it
more exciting because you get to kind of
use all those muscles at once have you
uh worked on something before where like
characters address the camera directly
or you know kind of break breaking that
fourth wall not in this way we
definitely talked about those moments
and and you know how to to make them
feel okay have them spaced out in a way
that you know you don't forget about it
and also there's not too much of it and
you know all those things and and and
then how to play those moment moment you
know miam's very playful in her film Mak
and um and that's one of the things in
this film that makes it really fun and
young and you know Poppy I was thinking
about this earlier because casting at
the beginning of a film and then editing
at the end you two probably have like
the closest collaboration with a writ or
director um in making a movie at the
start and at the end um and I just kind
of want to talk about you know your
collaboration with miam because she has
such a singular voice you're right
that's a really good observation that we
get to work with the director one on-one
for longer than anyone else as part of
the process and I think that's part of
what I love about my job is being able
to connect with someone with such a
creative strong exciting voice for so
long so closely it's
inspiring yeah um definitely I mean for
me too it's one of my favorite Parts
it's having that really close connection
and really trying to get into the mind
of what they're going for and hopefully
you know bringing ideas to the table
that they're equally excited about I was
a little concerned going in you know
this is such a personal story is she
going to be able is she going to be open
to two ideas and ultimately she would
kind of give me a hard time you know I'd
say I have something to show you and
she'd be like oh no what is it um and
then you know gently I would press play
and
uh and she she was really receptive um
she's actually a really great
collaborator usually ask what the most
challenging scene was to Cub but I'm
curious for you what's the one you're
most proud of the one that you you know
spent the most time on or you just
really you just felt like you finally
got it right one of the big ones I think
in the end was there was we're ending on
them they have this beautiful moment you
kind of want to stay in that moment a
little bit longer miam didn't want to
cut to a closeup of anybody in that
moment she wanted to stay in that three
shot but the shot was not long enough
yeah the shot was not long enough um so
we held it as long as we could we really
couldn't slow it down without it looking
terrible um so finally I tried a bunch
of different things I finally thought of
still going to Black at the same moment
but can but hearing the mother still
speaking
and that's where she says my love and I
felt like that gives you just enough
time to really settle into that moment
and and you know milk it for for every
second yeah I feel like we probably have
some actors here and and and the casting
process is so fascinating is there
anything you would want an actor to know
if they're you know lucky enough to meet
with you or even audition for you things
that might help them in that room when
an actor brings themselves to a
character and
and and their unique qualities it
creates a
specificity that breeds authenticity in
the character you believe it because
it's true and it's coming from a place
of honesty and so I would encourage any
actor to figure out what uniquely
connects them with a character and go
with it with
confidence that's great um I actually
want to remind the audience this movie
is in theaters now
um so you can display at the Grove I
believe so please spread the word it's
such a special film thank you so much
for being here and again congratulations
thank you so
much